Sarah Wagenknecht has now officially founded her party
and these are the members
she forms the dual leadership of the new party with Amira Mohammed Ali
Amira Mohamed Ali - this is the former head of the Left Party in the Bundestag
to classify them a bit politically
In an interview
In 2019,
Mohammed Ali declared
that it advocates open borders
ands categorically rejected deputyFraktionsvorsitzender
will Shervin Haghsheno
he was a university professor at the Kit until recently
Treasurer becomes Ralph Suikat
with him is interesting
he co-founded Tax me now
these are these heirs and entrepreneurs who desperately want to pay more taxes
he says
that he participates because he is concerned
about the economic policy of traffic lights
and his goal is his expertise as a start up founder and as he himself says
Mentor to contribute
Secretary General will be the formerBundestagsabgeordnete Christian Leye
previously he was with the left in NRW
politically,
he has so far advocated the reception of refugees 1
for the minimum wage and for strengthening trade unions
Party managing director with Lukas Schön
who used to lead the business of the NRW state association of the left
also with it is ex Europe MP De Masi
De Masi criticizes German export surpluses
and agreed with the position of Donald Trump's administration
one of his most famous quotes is "Germany live from the consumption of other
and honestly ne huge surprise was for me Thomas Geisel
he comes from the SPD and the düsseldorf ex-mayor
the new alliance Sarah Wagenknecht wants to get ready for the next 30 to 40
years to establish as a people's party - and as they say
Fundamentally change policy